>> DEAN: Yes, Flight of the Conchords.
Cool.
Okay.
So let's get started.
So many of you have probably used some of
Google's products and to a user, it sort of
looks like a bunch of different tools and
services that you can use that help you accomplish
various kinds of things; looking for information,
getting maps, checking your email, these kinds
of things.
What I'm going to talk about is a slightly
different view of Google which is more of
a computer scientist's view and the sort of
range of problems that we work on.
I'll talk about some of the computing systems
we've built behind the scenes that are used
for serving all these different products,
building different products on top of them.
One of the things that I think is interesting
about Google is that there's a really wide
range of areas that people work on and many
of the products that we work on cross lots
of these different areas.
So from that prospective, it's a really fun
and interesting place to be because you may
be an expert or good at one area but not know
much about another and you can work with colleagues
who know a lot about of different areas and
in that way, you can sort of learn more which
is always good.
So, I'm going to start at the very bottom
which is basically what our computing hardware
platform looks like.
One of our philosophies from very early on
in the company was that we were going to build
all of our systems on top of very low-end
commodity PCs.
Essentially, that's where all the volume is
in the market, that's where you get the most
bang for your buck.
In any case, you could buy very large machines
but most of our problems are large enough
that you'd have to parallelize things anyway
across lots of machines.
And given that you have to do that anyway,
you might as well go with a platform where
you get the most performance per dollar.
So, lots of commodity machines is what we
do.
In the very beginning when our two founders
were at Stanford, they started out with a
kind of a motley collection of machines they
found from other research groups.
They would head down to the loading back and
volunteer to set up machines for other research
groups and then they kind of used them for
three or four months before actually delivering
them.
And one problem with that approach is you
end up with a very heterogeneous collection
of machines with all kinds of different CPUs
and operating systems.
So we--and once the company was founded, we
ended up going with a more homogeneous set-up
made out of commodity components.
We actually were pretty bold in deciding we
would just assemble them ourselves by buying
a bunch of motherboards and discs and power
supplies.
So this is a very early design.
What you probably can't see is that there's
a tray and on top of that tray, there's four
machines all sharing a power supply.
Turns out not to be the best idea actually.
There's also a thin layer of cork insulating
the machines from the cookie tray that they're
sitting on.
And eventually, we decided that perhaps cork
was not an integral part of our computer architecture
and went with a slightly more traditional-looking
machine set up.
We tried to pack our machines pretty densely
just because you use your space more efficiently
and at this time, we were renting space in
data centers that we didn't know and so we
were leasing space in lots of different data
center providers.
And at that time, the data center providers
seemed to have a pricing model that charged
only by the square foot, so we had an incentive
to pack as many machines in as we could.
So we often had to help them a little bit
with cooling with a small fan we purchased
at Target.
The other thing we learned is that it's good
to have all your connectors on the front of
the machines.
The previous design did not have that property
which was kind of [INDISTINCT] and you'd end
up with crimped ethernet tables.
So based on a pricing model, we also got very
adept at moving out of bankrupt data centers.
So we ended up being able to move into new
data centers pretty quickly at that time.
We sort of had all the racks pre-assembled.
We just wheel them in and then you cable together
the rack switches to a central switch for
the whole cluster and away you go.
This is our current design.
We've kind of gone back and forth on whether
cases are a good idea.
We've now settled on no sort of cases because
it gives you better air flow.
But cables are a lot neater than that initial
design.
They're all basically commodity class PCs
that run Linux and a bunch of our own in-house
software that I'll describe, basically PC
class motherboards.
We kind of have a small number of different
configurations that we use basically not many
discs and a lot of discs.
That's kind of the extent of the different
configurations.
Everything within one data center tends to
be like the same generation of hardware and
then if we build the new data center, that
will be kind of whatever the best sweet spot
is in terms of price performance for that
when we build that data center.
So we have heterogeneity across different
data centers but typically not within the
same data center.
And this is kind of our current idea of what
multicore computing is.
This is our facility in Oregon that we opened
pretty recently.
It's a pretty large facility with lots of
machines in it.
And that's kind of the scale of machine, if
you like, that we're dealing with today.
Now, one problem with these commodity machines
is that if you have a lot of them, you end
up with kind of bizarre problems that are--just
happen because you have so many machines that
you are bound to see almost any kind of problem.
And this is thanks to one of our operations
folk--people.
They--he put together a list of the kinds
of things that tend to go wrong in the first
year of a cluster.
After that first year, though it gets a little
bit better.
So--but you see all kinds of things that you
wouldn't necessarily expect and that you really
have to be prepared to deal with in your software
in various ways like a whole rack going missing.
So 40 machines kind of drop off the face of
the earth and maybe just for a little while,
maybe for a long time.
Those actually aren't so bad.
The really sort of persnickety kinds of failures
are the ones that are not quite bad enough
to have the machine look dead but just kind
of look very slow or you get corrupted traffic
through network switches that sort of survive
TCB checks on errors and that kind of thing.
So those are kind of the more severe errors
where you have kind of Byzantine failures.
Okay.
So, given that that's the bedrock on which
we're building, the main issue is that you
have to really provide reliability at the
software level.
Anything you're running on a given machine,
you have to expect to be able to--that machine
might fail.
If you have, you know, one server, you may
not really have to worry about that server
failing.
But if you're running something on 10,000
machines, some of them are going to die everyday
and you have to really be prepared to deal
with that.
The other thing to notice is that if you spent
lots of money and bought ultra-reliable hardware
with redundant power supplies or rated discs,
that would help a little but you still have
lots of failures per day that you have to
deal with and those fancy features cost you
a lot in terms of dollars for the hardware.
So our view--our view is it's better twice
as much hardware that's much reliable than
half as much that's not as reliable.
Okay.
So the rest of this talk, I'm going to talk
a little bit about different pieces of infrastructures
we've--that we've built over the years to
take a big blob of commodity machines and
make them more useable as sort of a coherent
system as opposed to a bunch of individual
machines that you care about in an individual
manner.
I'll take a quick peek at how sort of when
a query comes in, it gets served on Google.com.
I'll look a little bit at our machine translation
system because I think that's kind of a fun
problem, talk about some interesting data
and then give you some thoughts about our
engineering style and philosophy and some
of the approaches we've developed to deal
with our source code base and so on.
Okay.
So given that you have a big pile of machines,
one of the first things you want to be able
to do is store data on them and you'd like
to be able to do that reliably given that
machines are failing.
So one of the first systems that we put together
at Google was a sort of large scale distributive
file system and the particular--this is called
the Google File System, GFS.
In this design, basically, we just take chunks
of files, 64 megabyte chunks, we're going
break files into those chunks, and each of
the chunks is going to have many copies of
it stored across different machines, typically
three copies per chunk.
So that if a machine goes bad, you have two
other copies of each chunk of data that was
managed by that machine that you can recover
that data from or use to make a third copy
now that you're down to two.
We have a centralized master in this file
system that is responsible for all the metadata
operations.
So when you open a file, the client goes and
talks to the master and says, okay, I'm going
to open this file.
Tell me where the chunks are, how big the
file is, et cetera.
And then the clients can talk directly to
chunkserver processes that are running on
all the machines and those chunkservers sort
of are responsible for reading data from chunks
off of local discs, sending it across the
network to clients.
One of the real advantages of this approach
is all the real bulk data transfer happens
between clients and the chunkservers directly.
The master is not really involved in that
once the files have been opened.
And so, you can get a very aggregate bandwidth
from this system.
You can have, you know, thousands of clients
talking to thousands of chunkservers and reading
at many tens of gigabytes per second out of
that file system.
So that's sort of our lowest level of systems
infrastructure system that runs across a bunch
of machines is a file system where you can
store lots of data.
It's sort of optimized for larger files than
a traditional file system.
We tend to--you know, if you crawl a bunch
of pages of the web, we don't put one file
per page, we just dump of bunch of, you know,
millions of pages into a single file and then
we process it from there.
You know, so today basically, GFS runs on
almost all of our machines.
We have a chunkserver running on most of our
machines.
The, you know--we have file systems that are
many petabytes in size and can support pretty
aggressive read and write leads.
And the master is responsible also for making
backup like monitoring the health of all the
chunkservers and making sure that the copies
of the chunks that are supposed to be there
are still there.
And if it notices a machine has fail or that
a chuck, a disc has gone bad or something,
it will go ahead and start making--basically
cloning copies of that chunk again so--to
get it back up to the desired replication
level.
So, essentially, what machine failures are
handle entirely by the GFS system at least
at the storage level.
Okay.
The next thing I'm going to talk about is
MapReduce.
Given that you have a file system, a pretty
natural thing to want to be able to do is
to run computations over data that you've
stored in a file system and perhaps compute
derived data.
One example might be, you have a bunch crawled
pages stored in a bunch files and you want
to process those pages in order to, I don't
know, count how often every word occurs or
maybe you want to compute an inverted index
where you take--you want to build for every
word a list of documents where that word occurs.
It's a pretty useful structure for the kinds
of things we do when we're serving queries
is you want to be able to offline, build an
index like that so you can tell for the query
New York restaurants what are the pages you
need to consider that have the word New and
York and restaurants in it.
So MapReduce is a way of taking large computations
like that that are actually pretty simple
to describe--you know, it's not that hard
to say, "I want to count how often every word
occurs."
The problems come because you need to be able
to run this computation across lots of thousands
of machines in order for it to compute--complete
in a reasonable amount of time.
And what we found was that over time, we were
ending up writing similar kinds of code all
the time that dealt with a lot of the issues
that MapReduce now deals with, things like,
"How am I going to take this computation and
spread it across thousands of machines?
How am I going to get load balancing across
the different machines so that, you know,
I don't end up with one machine that's got
a lot of the work towards the end of the job?
How can I ideally move computation close to
the data rather than having to transfer lots
and lots of data across the network and deal--how
can I deal with machine failures?"
And so MapReduce is an attempt to basically
abstract the programming model a little bit
and allow you to write fairly simple--a couple
of fairly simple functions and have the underlying
library take care of a lot of the details
for running those functions across your data
and on thousands of machines.
So the typical outline of something is you
want to read a bunch of input data, you want
to take each record which might be a crawled
page or something like that, extract something
you care about from every record.
You want to shuffle and sort the data and
then you want to reduce the data you extracted
in some way.
Maybe you want to [INDISTINCT] it all together,
maybe you want to add it up--add up counts
of how often every word occurs, that kind
of thing and then you want to produce your
output.
So let's looks at it in the context of processing
geographic data, for example, to produce the
kinds of map tiles that show up on Google
Maps where every image is kind of all the
roads in that square and rendered as map.
What you actually get to start with is a input
that is a list of features that you license
from, say, a third party map provider.
And they say, okay, here's a road, it intersects
with intersection number three and here's
the path the road takes.
Here's some intersection that intersects roads
one, two and five but I don't have any data
about each of the roads.
So one of the first things that I want to
be able to do is build a data structure that
for every intersection, I can tell--I can
basically join it with all the roads that
are entering that intersection so that I have
the directions of the roads.
So for example, intersection three, I want
to have the actual data for roads one, two
and five and for intersection six, I want
to have the actual data for roads four, five
and seven, so that I can eventually render
the map.
So this is pretty simple to describe; it's
a lot of--it's a fair amount of data.
In MapReduce, you would basically just read
the input.
If it's a road, you would figure out what
intersections it intersects with and emit
a key value pair for each of the intersections.
If it's an intersection, you would just propagate
the data there.
And then you would essentially, in the reduce
phase, have all the data for each intersection
and be able to apply whatever computation
you wanted to join together; the complete
details of the intersection including all
the road information.
And so that's pretty easy to describe.
It's not much code.
I don't want you to actually read the code,
but give you a sense of, you know, how much
code you might have to write in order to able
to run this.
And let's look at one more example which is
now once, I've got my intersections, I want
to be able to render map tiles.
So the second example is, in the map phase,
I'm going to have a key that I'm going to
designate for each map tile I want to render.
So each square on the earth, I'm going to
have a square, and then in the map phase,
I'm going to go through all the intersections,
all the roads and if any road intersects a
particular map tile, I'm going to emit it
to that map tile's key.
And in the reduce phase, it's going to join
together all the data for a particular map
tile and I'm going to get a list of all the
roads that have any intersection with that
map tile and I can then clip to the map tile
boundary and then render that road.
So for example, if you know Seattle I-5 runs
north-south, so we'll emit I-5 to both of
these two map tiles.
Uh, the 520 Bridge run east-west and it only
interests with the top tile, so we'll just
emit it to the top one.
We'll emit I-90 to the bottom one and then
so on with all the other roads.
And you could then end up being able to render
all those tiles.
It turns out that this programming model is
actually pretty easy to describe a pretty
broad and diverse set of problems in.
And there are a lot of uses that we make of
it inside Google.
I'll show you some data about, you know, number
of map reductions people have written over
time.
But it's used in a really wide range of areas.
Our original motivation was to write a system
for building our indexing pipeline where you
start with a bunch of raw pages on disc and
you ultimately want to end up with sort of
an inverted index of, you know, words to list
the documents and some other data about the
documents.
But there's a bunch of phases in between.
You want to eliminate duplicate content.
You want to, you know, maybe compute page
rank for the--based on the graph structure
of the pages that you've crawled and so on.
So we originally wrote it for that purpose
and it's been used in a lot of other contexts
as well.
Underneath the cover, what really happens
is that we--when you run a map reduction,
you set up a little structure that says, okay,
here's my map function, here's my reduce function,
here's the number of machines I want to use
and here's the input files I want to run my
map reduction over.
And then there's a master that's started up
and a bunch of worker machines, you know,
could be ten, could be several thousand.
And the master is going to start assigning
work to the worker machines that check in
with it.
And one of the things it does is it tries
to direct workers to read pieces of the input
data that they have on local desk, so it finds
out where the different chunks are of the
files are located on GFS and it's going to
tell this work--the, you know, the upper right
hand worker to read data that is ideally on
that same machine or at least on the same
rack, so that you don't need to use a lot
of aggregate network bandwidth to read input
data across, say, from a different rack in
your same data center.
One of our precious commodities is network
bandwidth, so we try to do optimizations like
that that help preserve that.
And each map task is going to be started which
is going to--a map task is basically going
to read a chunk of the input data, apply the
map function to each of the chunks and then
emit the data that's produced by the map function
to a local file on the local disk.
And then the master is also going to assign
a reduce task to a bunch of reduce workers
and each of those reduce workers is going
to ask the map workers that have data for
it to send their data over the network.
So basically, there's a bunch of RPCs that
happen to shuffle the data across the network.
And then the reduce workers sort things to
combine together all the data for the same
key and then apply the reduce function too
so that you could say, fine, I have this map
tile, here's all the data that was emitted
with that map tile key and you can apply the
reduce function to do that.
And then the output of the reduce function
is emitted to a bunch of files.
So that's kind of an overview of the operation.
When a machine fails, the master nodes which
map tasks that machine had accomplished or
which reduce task that machine was assigned,
and will direct all the other machines to
recover--to take up the map tasks that are
now--that were on a now dead machine.
One of the nice things about this is we try
to make the map tasks fairly fine grained.
So a given worker might do a hundred map tasks
in the course of a map reduction.
And so if a machine fails, you end up losing
the hundred map tasks that have been completed
but you can have each of a hundred other machines
each pick up one of those map tasks.
And so recovery from failure is very, very
quick.
We actually were--at one point, we were running
a map reduction and our operations folks,
unbeknownst to us, were doing maintenance
on our clusters.
So we were running a MapReduce on 1,800 machines
and they were unplugging all the networks
switches from groups of, like, 80 machines
at a time.
So they would unplug 80 machines, they'd drop
off the network, we'd lose the work and it
would get redone by , you know, the other
1,720 machines.
And then they'd unplugged the next group as
we were progressing.
It ran a little slowly but it actually all
completed which is kind of a testament to
how robust this stuff can be.
All right.
The other thing you got by using this sort
of centralized library is you got kind of
a common status report about how your job
is progressing.
You know, early on, the green is kind of assigned
map tasks but not completed.
The red is now completed map tasks so there's
a bunch of completed map task in the bottom
left there.
And some map tasks being worked on.
The reduced tasks are sort of in blue as the
reduced work progresses for each of the different
reduced partitions.
The blue kind of builds up and that's kind
of very close to the end of the job.
So you got this centralized status reporting
and monitoring and so on.
So we originally wrote the first version of
MapReduce in early '03 and then wrote another
version that had much higher performance in
kind of end of '03.
And it's had a bunch of other optimizations
and iterations done in the design as we've
scaled the kinds of map, you know, the sizes
of map reductions we've been trying to do.
We now have, you know, upwards of 10,000 different
MapReduce programs in our source tree.
If you take the derivative of that graph,
you see that the number of new MapReduce programs
per month has been growing fairly steadily.
One of the things you might notice is that
every summer, we have a bunch of summer interns
kind of show up and they're actually--you
know, they work really hard for the whole
summer.
And then at the end of the summer, they try
to check in all their code and so we end up
with a big spike towards the end of the summer
when they're going to check in all their code.
And it's kind of--most of these interns don't
have a lot of experience in running, writing
large, you know, scale high performance distributed
computations.
And they are still able to sort of make use
of MapReduce to run jobs on lots of machines
and get work accomplished which is kind of
the whole goal is you want to be able to have
this infrastructure that takes care of a lot
of these details for you so you can concentrate
on what is it you're really trying to do rather
than dealing with machine failures.
It's just some statistics over time of, you
know, how much we've been using MapReduce
for various things.
You know, we now run about a hundred thousand
MapReduce jobs per day.
And they use, you know, an average 400 machines
each roughly.
You know, a lot of machines years of used
in September.
The job is complete pretty quickly, you know,
about 5 or 10 minutes or something even though
they're running on lots of machines.
So it's been pretty heavily used and has grown
in utility and sort of it's integration into
our source base over time.
Okay.
Let's switch gears a bit one more time and,
well, the first of many.
Let's talk about a system called Big Table.
So Big Table is a system that we started working
on a few years ago to allow us to have a slightly
higher level view of data than a file system.
It's kind of like a database except it doesn't
do sort of relations or drawings.
It's really designed for semi-structured data.
We have a lot of that kind of data at Google,
so we have, you know, for our crawling system,
it goes out and fetches pages and we have
different kinds of data about every URL.
We have sort of meta-information like when
did we last crawl this page?
What happened when we tried to crawl it?
Did we, you know, get a success code back
or did we get a 404?
That kind of thing.
We have the actual contents of the page which
are pretty big.
We have information about the links from each
page.
We have kind of the inversion of that which
is what are the links that point to this page?
We have page rank which is kind of this offline
graph computation we run and want to be able
to update and get data.
Similarly, we have per-user data where users
want to be able to set their preferences of
what their preferred language is, what are
their recent queries and search results so
that we can show them their history.
And more recently, we've been dealing with
a lot of geographic kinds of data and in particular,
satellite imagery is a fairly large, bulky
kind of thing.
So in all these cases, the scale is pretty
large and, you know, many, mane terabytes
or petabytes in many cases.
And we want to be able to have pretty high
volume access to it.
So, one approach would be to use a commercial
database of some sort.
One problem with that approach is that the
scale is pretty large even for the pretty
high-end commercial databases.
And even if it weren't, when you have a really
large scale database that you need to use,
the price that you pay is often quite high
for commercial databases.
So by building this system internally that
was more suited to our needs and a little
bit more tailored to our needs, we can also
then amortize the cost of building it across
lots and lots of different projects.
And once you've built it and can use it for
10 projects, the 11th one is pretty easy to
use it for and has a very low marginal cost.
The other thing is we can integrate a lot
of low level storage optimizations into our
system that would be hard to do if we were
running on top of a commercial database layer.
We do a lot of compression inside our system
even across different rows.
We're integrated pretty tightly with GFS so
that we can give hints about placement of
where a chunk should go so that we can get
locality.
And another reason we decided to build it
is it was kind of fun to build things like
this.
So the basic data model that we provide for
big table is essentially a distributed multi-dimensional
sparse map.
So what do I mean by that?
There--you can think of it as a triple that
maps from a row and a column name and a timestamp
to some cell contents.
And the cell contents we just treat as a uninterpreted
binary stream of bytes.
So the rows typically and, you know, in one
example, if you wanted to maintain data about
URLs, the row name would be the URL.
We might have a column for the contents, we
might have another column for, you know, when
was the last time we crawled it, another one
for the page rank of the page.
We found it useful in our systems to maintain
historical data, to keep multiple versions
of a particular row and column so that we
can look at how things have changed over time
or look at various trends.
And that three dimensional model seems to
be a pretty good match for a lot of applications
that we want to build.
Let's see.
So the way we actually implement this system
is the row names are sorted and so when you
create a new table, it essentially starts
out with a bunch of empty rows and as you
add data to it, you have a bunch of rows and
columns.
A column doesn't have to exist and so it doesn't
exist until you actually write data into that
column.
Over time, you'll end up filling up the data
and one of the important properties we wanted
was the system should be largely self-managing.
So if I start adding more and more data to
the system, I don't want to have to have some
heavyweight sort of manual process whereby
I say, "Oh, gee, now, I need 200 machines
instead of 100 to maintain my data."
I want the system to be able to sort of automatically
adjust to more data or maybe I can throw more
machines at it and have it automatically adjust
to more machines even if I haven't added more
data to the system.
So the main way we deal with that is the unit
of, uh, serving is something called the tablet,
which is essentially a continuous range of
rows in this large table.
And a given table may be made up of lots and
lots of tablets.
When you add more data to a tablet or to a
table, eventually, a tablet will up and will
decide it's too large and we want to split
it into multiple pieces.
Two, actually.
And so we'll pick a row that's roughly in
the middle of the size profile of the different
rows in the tablet and we'll just say fine,
we're going to now spit apart the state that
was maintained in that system and now we have
two independent tablets and those tablets
can now be moved around the system and responsibility
for serving those tablets can be moved from
one machine to another.
So the representation of a tablet is basically
a--you can think of it as a infinite length
log that we truncate periodically by check-pointing
the state into a special file format we call
an SS table.
It's basically just a key to value map where
the keys are basically combinations of row,
column, and timestamp and the value is the
actual bytes there.
So when you got to write, you append to a
log that's stored in GFS and you also represent
that write in memory for a little while so
that you have fast random access to recently
written data.
Eventually, your memory fills up and you decide
to dump it to one of these files on disk.
So you take all the--you find the table that
has the most buffered updates, you dump it
to an SS table on disk that's going to represent
a range of that log, and then you can then
truncate the log and remove the prefix of
the log because you now have representation
of the data in the SS table file.
When a read comes in, you essentially look
in your in-memory buffer and you then also
maybe look on the on-disk SS tables seek--doing
a seek for that particular key that you're
looking for.
You may need to look in multiple SS tables.
We also allow you to specify that certain
data--certain columns essentially should be
mapped into memory.
And so, those data--those SS table get mapped--and
mapped and you can do very fast high volume
operations on--data mapped in the memory.
Maybe you go directly to memory in some cases,
skipping the on disk ones.
So, like a lot of our systems, the structure
of Big Table is that we have a centralized
master and then we have a bunch of serves
that are going to be responsible for actually
serving data.
The--underneath the covers, we have--well,
sitting underneath this, we have GFS where
all the state for Big Table is stored.
So, all the SS Table files and the log files
are written into GFS and when a tablet migrates
from one machine to another, that other tablet--that
other machine will read whatever state is
needed to recover out of GFS.
We have a clustered scheduling system where
we can say, "I want to schedule a job that
is my tablet servers with 400 instances for
those, because I want to run 400 tablet servers,"
or you can change it to be 500 and then the
master will notice that now there are 500
tablet serves and sort of rebalance the serving
state.
We also have a lock service that we use to
do master elections, although we only have
a single master running that is making decisions
on the cluster.
I'm not going to talk much about that.
And then we have a client library that we
link into our applications that, when it wants
to open a file, it talks to the lock service
to find out where the master is.
When it wants to read and write data, it talks
directly to the tablet server and metadata
operations like creating a new table go to
the master.
Pretty straightforward.
The status of this is that, over time, kind
of like MapReduce, we started out with a few
applications in mind, some that were fairly
latency sensitive, so we were actually serving
real user requests behind some of those applications
and other ones were more batch style crawling
system kinds of things where you just want
to have a larger repository of data and have
it in a slightly more structured format.
And over time, the number of applications
that are using this--that using this system
has grown a lot and we now do satellite imagery
processing in Big Table.
We do or [INDISTINCT] is served heavily off
of Big Table.
All kinds of things.
Use this kind of as a low-level building block
for building your applications.
And we have, you know, the biggest cells tend
to have several thousand tablet servers running,
managing, you know, many petabytes of data
and shuffling data around to look balance
load and so on, dealing with machine failures.
So again, a given machine is responsible for
serving many tablets.
So when a machine fails, the master notices
this and your recovery is very fast because
we end up taking the 100 tablets that were
served by that machine and having each of
a hundred other machines each pick up responsibility
for one of those tablets.
And they each recover in parallel the state
so that, you know, within a second or two,
typically, you can recover all the serving
state of a particular machine if that machine
does.
Let's see.
So, the three systems I've talked about and
a bunch of other ones that I haven't talked
about, mostly, their--a particular instance
of GFS or Big Table tends to run within a
single cluster of machines.
They don't tend to run across a really wide
area so we don't run a single Big Table cell
with half the machines in Atlanta and half
in Oregon.
We would run multiple Big Table cells.
We do have replication systems set up so you
can kind of keep Big Table cells in rough
consistencies.
So writes done in Atlanta in one Big Table
cell can be propagated to a different Big
Table cell in Oregon.
You can kind of configure that.
But one of the--one of the--one of the things
that we really noticed now is that we really
want sort of our next generation infrastructure
to be a system that runs across all of our
machines or a large fraction of our machine
rather than having separate instances.
So, one of thing--one of the advantages that
would give is we would have a single global
name space for all of our data.
Right now, when you put files in GFS and--in
one cell and then you copy those files to
another cell, they have different names, like
it's GFS/Oregon and GFS/Atlanta.
And we've lost the association of those files
are the same or are meant to be, you know,
copies of each other.
So, what we really want is to have a single
name space where you can add replicas of particular
pieces of data but keep the fact that that
data is the same.
We'd also, in some, cases like stronger consistency
across different data centers.
Right now, the Big Table replication system
gives you eventual consistency so if a data
center is partitioned and then that partition
is healed, all the writes will eventually
propagate, but in the meantime, you have kind
of weekly consistent semantics.
We'd also like to be able to say things like
"This data is important.
I want it on two disks in Europe, two in the
U.S. and one in Asia and I don't really care
which particular data centers it lives in."
One of the big problems we have is because
we run so many individual GFS cells or Big
Table cells and humans have to make a decision
now where they're going to store their data
and when they want to change which GFS cell
they store their data, that's kind of a less
automated operation than you might like.
So, the design goal of our next generation
systems is that we want to be much more automated
in how systems run across different data centers.
We're pretty automated at the--within cluster
level.
So, machine failures and all that kind of
thing are taken care of pretty well by our
existing infrastructure but across clusters
and data centers, we're not as good as we
might hope.
So, we want to be able to automatically move
jobs, move data automatically, shrink and
grow capacity of jobs as, you know, request
loads change and so on.
Okay?
I just have one slide on this that I figure
everyone is kind of curious about what happens
when a query comes in to Google.
So, one of the things that sort of may not
be obvious to many people is that there are
a huge number or subsystems involved in processing
that query.
So, when a query comes in, it's routed by
our front end networking hardware to a particular
web server that's going to kind of coordinate
the whole process for getting the results
to show for that query.
And initially, the system was relatively simple.
We had kind of index servers that have a inverted
index of the documents in our index, so they
map from--for a subset of the documents, they
each have a local copy of an inverted index
which is, for each word, what are the documents
that occurs in and maybe some other per document
data like how important is this page or, you
know, various other kinds of things.
And so, when a query comes in, you send a
request to one copy of each of the different
partitions of the index, thus those four lanes
going to I--zero through In things.
You have many replicas of each of that piece
of index data so that you can handle the query
volume and some of--this is showing one data
set and you might have many other sort of
replicas of this entire set-up in different
data centers.
And each of these local index shards computes
one of the best results for this query for
it--for its subset of the documents.
So given the query, you say New York restaurants,
it will compute what are the best results
for its, you know, few million documents,
send back the results of the top five or ten
and then you'd essentially merge those results
by score across all the deferent pieces of
the index and you figure out one of the results
you actually want to show is the top 10 results
on the result page.
Once you figure that out, you essentially
are just getting identifiers of the documents
back from the index system and you need do
then send the request down to what we called
dock servers which are responsible for taking
that identifier in the query and computing
the, you know, the little summary of the page,
the title and the snippet for the page.
One thing to notice is that the snippets we
compute are query sensitive, so if I do a
query, New York restaurants, that matches
a page, that may be a different snippet even
for the same document for some other query
that matches the page.
In the meantime, there's a bunch of other
systems that are involved in processing the
query.
We added a spelling checking system a long
time ago, an ad system.
And the ad system itself is composed of lots
and lots different components.
Over time, we've been adding more and more
different kinds of corpuses that can searched
like news, different books that we've scanned,
blogs, various kinds of things like that,
and we now sort of in parallel with the request
to the main web index do requests to all those
other corpora and try to show those on our
results page if we think that a book result
is appropriate for this particular query.
That's actually an interesting problem is
when do you figure--how can you figure out
for this query what results you want to show
and from what corpora make the most sense.
Okay.
Switch gears yet again.
Let me talk a little bit about our machine
translation system because there is some interesting
systems problems behind that.
So, the goal with machine translation is basically
you want to take text in one language and
translate it to text in another and you want
to do that in a way that gives you as understandable
as possible a translation.
So, the approach that a group at Google is
using is called statistical machine translation.
So, machine translation is not really a new
concept.
It started many, many years ago, I think,
in the '70s with a rule-based system where
you say, for this word in English, I'm going
to translate it to this word in French or
maybe this phrase.
And over time, you build up more and more
rules that allow you to do better and better
translations.
The Statistical Approach is completely different.
Basically, you start with a bunch of training
data.
And there are two main kinds of training data.
One is called parallel aligned corpora where
I have a bunch of text in one language and
a bunch of translated versions of those sentences
in the other languages.
And I build this statistical model that says,
okay, I see this English sentence and then
I see the corresponding French sentence.
I'm going to compute statistics over all the
words and phrases that I see in those sentences
and I'll come up with a model that's says,
well, if hello is in the input sentence then
with probability .87, the word Bonjour is
in the corresponding French sentence.
And so you essentially get a model of word
by word and phrase by phrase replacements.
The other thing that's really helped a lot
in recent years is the ability to have what's
called a target language model because the
problem with it is you can't get many--you
can't get much in the way of parallel aligned
corpora.
There just aren't that many corpuses that
have really huge amounts of sentence by sentence
translations for all language pairs.
But one of the things that can really help
is if you have--you use the parallel model
to generate a bunch of candidate translations
and then you can use the target language model
to pick the most natural sounding ones of
the candidates.
So, let me give you an example.
Let's say I have two candidate sentences that
I--that I--are translations candidates and
I want to pick the one that sounds the most
natural.
I'm going to look up each five-word sequence
in a target language model and if I find that
this five-word has sequences occurred in all
of our English documents three times and this
other segments has a five-word sequence that's
never occurred, it's more likely to be that
I should go with the one that's occurred three
times.
So, the more data you can train the system
on, the better it's going to be.
So essentially, you end up wanting to build
these target language models on really, really
large amounts of text.
Basically all the documents that we can get
our hands on.
And so you end up with a relatively large
model even after you've just summarized it
by counting how often every five-word sequence
occurs.
And it turns out that the translation process
need to actually look up data in this model
quite a lot, unfortunately, like a hundred
thousand to a million look-ups per sentence
that you want to translate.
And the model is one and half terabytes in
size.
So you--we--you know, in typical fashion we
just spread it across a bunch of machines
and do look-ups.
So it seems to work pretty well.
And one of the things that target language
model really helps is the translation quality,
so this is a competition that's run annually
or every few years, I guess, by the National
Institute of Standards and it has a bunch
of competitors submitting their machine translation
systems.
And this Y-axis is the BLEU score of how good
the translations were on some test data set
and Google did quite well in these competitions.
We can think of the BLEU score as sort of
the fraction of overlap of the translation
system with a collection of human translations
of the same documents.
And it actually doesn't really go to a hundred
because even if you had another human translate
it, it wouldn't give you a hundred percent
because they tend to translate things differently
as well.
So, let me show you a non-Google translation
system that's available on the web.
I won't say which one.
And you can kind of try to read those middle
paragraphs.
It's--it doesn't flow real well I would say.
And here's the same text translated through
Google's Arabic to English translation system.
And what you see is the impact of having a
really large language model makes the sentences
flow a lot more naturally.
So, if you read those middle two sentences
there, you know, they're not perfect grammatically--perfectly
grammatically formed, but they're a lot better
than the other system.
And as you might expect, the more training
data that you use for your target language
model, the better your BLEU score is going
to be.
And so, roughly a redoubling of your training
size for your language model gives you a little
bit higher BLEU score which is kind of cool.
So, more data is generally good which is in
part why we've been focusing a lot on building
infrastructure to process large data sets
and, you know, do things like computing your
language model fairly quickly or try out different
things in how we apply the language model
to translation or any of a hundred other things
because the quicker you can turn around these
kinds of experiments, the quicker you'll be
able to sort of improve things.
Here's just another example of, you know,
having the right tools makes it so people
can kind of ask questions.
So, someone at Google who worked on our book
scanning group said, Gee, it'd be kind of
cool to know where different locations were
mentioned in books and how that's changed
over time."
So, they essentially, you know, took all the
scanned books we've scanned which is I think
more than a million books today, figured out,
you know, applied a geographic place name
recognizer to all the text, took the extracted
locations and plotted them by year the book
was published.
And plotted the density of how often those
things were mentioned.
And it's kind of interesting data, you know,
it's heavily biased towards English books
because we tend to scan more English books
than other kinds of books but you can sort
of see the expansion from Europe to the rest
of the world in terms of the publishing industry
at least.
Kind of fun.
You know, and being able to, you know, take
questions like that and in a couple of hours,
have a rough at that data is kind of fun.
So, let me switch gears a bit again and talk
about some of our software engineering approaches
for managing our source code base and our
projects as Google has grown over time.
So, one of the things that I think is interesting
for a company our size now is that we still
have one large shared source space.
So, we have thousands of developers working
on the same source code base.
There's a lot of lower level libraries that
are used by almost everything.
There's a bunch of higher level libraries
that are shared across multiple projects that
are kind of doing similar kinds of things.
And then there's a bunch of application specific
code.
Now, one of the big advantages of having this
single repository is that, you know, improvements
in this core library benefit everyone.
You don't have this sort of splintering effect
when you break your code into multiple repositories
and then break things into different groups
and those groups then kind of stop talking
to each other and just work on their own source
code and polishing their own libraries.
And you don't get the benefit of those libraries
sort of benefiting everyone, but they benefit
just a small subset of your [INDISTINCT] group.
So, that's one of the main benefits and it's
also easy to find, you know, example code
of, you know, how is someone using this library
function or what's the best way to count how
often different things occur.
Can I find the Map Reduction that does close
to what I want and maybe modify it or at least
look at the code and see how they're doing
it.
So, that's a pretty huge benefit.
There are, of course, some drawbacks which
is that you sometimes have these kind of tangled
dependencies that instead of just looking
at some piece of code, someone has said, oh,
I'll just, you know--oh, I'm in Blogger and
I'm going to link into the middle of the book
scanning project and use their library for
doing this because it does exactly what I
want.
And, you know, that happens.
One of the things that we've found pretty
essential is that it's really helpful to be
able to quickly search all of our source code.
So, one of the things I did a few years ago
was built a little internal tool that's not
particularly fancy, you know.
Using a lot of the machines, you just spread
the requests over--spread the data over lots
of machines and you just can run--basically
grab in parallel across all of our source
code.
So within, you know, quarter to a second,
you can search all of our code and find, you
know, examples, uses.
It's very helpful if you're maintaining low
level libraries so that you can find, you
know, everyone who uses this routine.
What if I change the semantics or what if
I want to add an argument?
What would--you know, what would that do to
all the different call sites of this routine?
So that's pretty helpful.
We have pretty disciplines afternoon practice,
so we tend to code--every piece of code that's
checked in is code reviewed by at least one
person.
We do a lot of design reviews before writing
a lot of code.
Lots and lots of testing.
The testing is done for individual modules.
Larger tests for all the systems.
We have a continuous testing framework that
is always running all of our tests.
Most of our development work is done in C++
Java and Python and the way it kind of breaks
down is anything touched by, say, a web query
is done in C++ and a bunch of other things
as well.
Java tends to be used in lower volume applications
like the advertising front end that advertisers
log into to get reports and so on.
That's not quite as performance critical as
the code that runs on every web search and
so that tends to be done in Java.
Parts of Gmail are done that way and Python
tends to be used for configuration and so
on.
The other interesting change over the last
few years has been we've moved from being
a, you know, a Mountain View-only engineering
organization to one that has many, many engineering
sites all around the world in the last few
years.
And the motivation for that for that is obvious.
You somehow can't convince everyone in the
world to move to Mountain View.
And so you want to hire really good candidates
regardless of where they actually are living.
And so we've opened up engineering sites close
to where we think we can hire really good
people.
There's obviously a bunch of issues with having
of lots of small and medium-sized offices
is that you need more coordination of who's
doing what.
Communication is hard.
You can't just kind of bump into people in
the hallway.
And establishing trust between remote teams
working on the same source code base is sometimes
tricky when you just haven't met someone face
to face.
But, you know, there--we've developed a bunch
of techniques.
First, we put all of our documentation and
source code online.
Well, I mean source code is obviously online.
We tend to use video conferencing and email
a fair amount.
Careful choices of how, who's going to work
on what tends to make it so that you can try
to break things at the sort of minimal communication
cut boundary so that this group can define
an interface to the spelling system and can
go off and work on it and these people can
use the spelling system through that fairly
narrow API.
Ad the spelling system folks can roll out
new releases whenever they want without a
lot of coordination with everyone else.
That helps a lot.
The Big Table project is split across three
sites.
I tend to work pretty closely with some of
the New York.
We have an--actually an office of people in
New York and we actually just have a permanent
little portable video conferencing unit permanently
hooked up to their office and we just keep
each other muted all the time.
We can kind of un-mute and say, hey, hi, I'm
thinking of changing this code.
It's actually better than having an office
of six people is to have two offices of three
people in different places because they're
very quiet, at least when they're muted.
And I think, you know, one of the things that
I really like about Google is that it's a
really fun environment to write software.
You know, there's a really interesting range
of problems and people who have different
ranges of expertise.
You can learn a lot about other areas.
For example, the machine translation system,
I didn't know anything about machine translation
but I knew they were having some issues with
how can they do look up some of this large
language model.
And so I went off and worked with them for
a little while in building this large language
model serving system and, you know, I learned
a little about machine translation, they learned
a little about how to distribute computations
across lots of machines.
And the end result is something that probably
neither one of us could have produced alone.
So, it's fun.
I obviously covered a lot of ground; not much
in depth.
So there's a bunch of papers and other papers
available that have a lot of details about
some of the systems I talked about.
And I'll take any questions.
Yeah.
>> [INDISTINCT]
>> Oh, yeah.
Is there--I guess there's a microphone for
questions there.
Now, you're third in line.
>> Let me just ask you.
You mentioned about the masters, the masters
and the slaves.
Are you using any special hardware for the
masters compared to the slaves?
>> DEAN: No.
>> It's the same?
>> DEAN: Yeah, it's basically, you know, our
scheduling system will pick, you know, a hundred
and one machines, one of which will be started
up as the master and a hundred of which might
be workers.
>> Okay, the same hardware?
>> DEAN: Same hardware.
>> Thank you.
>> DEAN: It makes things simpler.
If you end up with a small number of machines
that are very specialized for masters, it's
kind of an operations nightmare.
>> Google is pretty good about scaling across
the--a bunch of distributed machines, how
about scaling kind of deep down into the new
multi-cores that are going to come out?
Are you going to do anything special or just
follow the commodity?
>> DEAN: Well, we really, really like multi-core
machines because we've already had to parallelize
our computations across lots and lots of machines
and essentially, to us, multi-core machines
just look like lots of little machines with
really good interconnects.
And so from that perspective, I think it's
relatively easy for us to use multi-core machines
because we're already sort of used to parallelizing
things, breaking things and running multiple
threads anyway.
So, yeah, multi-core machines are great.
We're very happy because single-thread performance
doesn't matter to us at all, not completely
at all, but to a large extent, we have lots
of parallelizable problems and we're totally
happy breaking them up.
>> I have a question about overall architecture.
There seems to be a trend nowadays, you've
talked of vendors like Sun, they tell you
go get a Blade system and the blades don't
have disks on them and then they talk to some
other kind of disk system over here.
Do you think that's a mistake in your opinion
to go kind of separated protection?
>> DEAN: Well, I think--you know, I guess
you're talking about storage area networks
or, you know, fiber channel based disks where
you can access them for multiple machines.
>> So you're--all the Google stuff seems to
say, okay, do the computation and data in
the same place.
>> DEAN: I mean, I think those systems have
their place but they--for example, if you're
running a commercial database and you need
a really high performance disk system, you
might buy one of those because that's a really
easy way for you to get a high performance
disk system that can run underneath the commercial
database.
But in our case, we--you know, we're happy
using cheap disks attached to lots and lots
of machines because you get a lot more spindles
for the same price, you get a lot more disk
storage capacity for the same price, and you
got a lot more computation near your disk
for the same price.
So, if you're willing to build things yourself
or use, you know, open source versions of
things like, you know, the [INDISTINCT] project
has an open source MapReduce and an open source
of version of GFS, those kind of things, I
think, can make it possible to use the techniques
that we use on lots of commodity machines
and not buying into a large, you know, storage
area network, for example.
So--but obviously, you have to evaluate what
makes sense for the kinds of problems you're
trying to solve.
>> Speaking of that, some of the problems
here described including distributing it a
large number of machines seem to be pretty
unique to Google and their--especially their
solutions seem to be pretty unique to Google.
So you can't buy a commercial database like
Oracle then.
You have to you're your own files [INDISTINCT]
does that create a challenge in terms of being
able to train new set of recruits?
How long does it take for a typical programmer
to join and be productive and come up with
a new application?
>> DEAN: Right.
So, I think one of the things that we've done
a pretty good job at is because we've been
hiring quite quickly and growing pretty fast,
we've had to create a lot of online documentation
and sort of initial training material to teach
people about the systems we've built and I
think we've done a pretty good job of that.
So, when someone is hired, they go in and
can pick and choose from a collection of,
like, 10 or 12 kind of half day courses and
about, you know, how to use MapReduce or how
to use GFS or how to use our source control
system, that kind of thing.
And so I think, you know, we've gotten pretty
good at bringing people up to speed relatively
quickly.
That said, there is a lot of stuff to learn
when people join.
And I've heard new people who are fairly experienced
when they join, say, wow, that's--there's
a lot--it's like drinking from a fire hose
kind of thing.
But, you know, I think the desire to just
jump in and learn stuff is the main thing
that will keep people above water.
Okay.
I gather we're out of time.
I'm happy to hang around in the hall and answer
questions if people have them.